bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver notre
grand témoin ce soir c'est vous Ségolène
Royal bonsoir et merci d'être là
ancienne ministre et candidate à la
présidentielle vous nous appelez dans
votre dernier livre à refuser la cruauté
du monde c'est le titre aux éditions du
Rocher c'est une Aude à l'amour à la
bienveillance contre tout ce qui nous
gouvernerait par la peur et ils sont
nombreux on le verra tout à l'heure ça
tombe bien en étant ensemble pendant une
heure on va évidemment commencer ce soir
par la crise politique post 49-3 sur les
retraites Emmanuel Macron on s'exprime
demain à 13h mais pour dire quoi quels
sont ces options pour relancer et
reprendre la main comment gouverner
après avoir échappé de neuf voix à la
censure le président est-il condamné à
l'impuissance et notre grand débat dans
un instant ce soir avec nos invités
avant de retrouver bien sûr à 20h15 nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express ce soir gros plan sur
les républicains en pleine décomposition
vous me suivez Ségolène Royal à tout de
suite ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
comment peut-il s'en sortir la crise des
retraites déclenchée par le recours aux
49.3 la affaiblit et isolée Emmanuel
Macron cherche à relancer son
quinquennat mais en a-t-il vraiment les
moyens bonsoir Elsa vous êtes à l'Élysée
ou plutôt devant l'Élysée où sont reçus
ce soir tous les députés de la majorité
Renaissance horizon modem vous allez
nous dire quel est le moral des troupes
avant l'intervention importante de
demain du président de la République et
puis quatre fines l'âme ce soir sur ce
plateau pour décrypter décrypter ce
moment à nouveau riche en
rebondissements aujourd'hui Dominique
Rousseau bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes constitutionnalistes
professeur émérite de droit
constitutionnels à l'université parisien
Panthéon Sorbonne Carole Barjon bonsoir
merci de nous accompagner à nouveau ce
soir dans cette émission éditorialiste à
lobs j'aurais mis Bodo bonsoir merci
aussi de votre fidélité journaliste
politique à France Info et chroniqueurs
dans cette émission enfin bonsoir
Raphaël
il y a quelques saisons on est ravi de
vous retrouver vous êtes journaliste
désormais politique
après avoir suivi l'économie toujours un
pied dans l'économie quand même
allopinion bien sûr c'est Glenn Royal
évidemment vous intervenez quand vous le
souhaitez dans ce débat on a de vous
entendre sur cette crise des retraites
mais on va commencer comme chaque soir
par planter le décor avec le billet de
Stéphane blackovski consultation avant
intervention le chrono de la côte tout
de suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir à vous bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
madame Royal la bonsoir à toutes à vrai
dire bonsoir à tous le président de la
République sort donc du silence demain
écoutez oui ça fait vraiment très très
longtemps que j'ai pas regardé un
journal de 13h ni sur TF1 ni sur France
2 mais demain je serai devant mon poste
bah forcément avec l'ampleur que la
contestation prend dans le pays je suis
à peu près comme tout le monde je suis
curieux de savoir ce que le président va
dire comment il compte faire face à
cette nouvelle situation parce que à
l'Assemblée bon pas la benne d'être
constitutionniste pour avoir compris que
ça y est c'était la motion de censurer
était rejetée c'est fait en revanche
dans la rue et bien on voit que depuis
ce vote elle a contestation elle se
poursuit les chaînes info il suffit de
les allumer le soir pour voir que les
incidences multiplient là c'était hier
soir à Paris hier à Rennes et puis c'est
presque encore plus grave aussi des
questions de pénurie d'essence qui
commence à se poser avec certains
blocages là c'est une station dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône ou malgré des
réquisitions et bien on a du mal à faire
le plein ça risque d'être le cas bien
sûr dans d'autres départements alors
forcément nous sommes en France donc
tout dépend du président et on se tourne
vers lui que va dire de président
qu'est-ce qu'il va nous annoncer donc
Olivier d'Iran préparer le terrain ce
matin sur RTL il nous a pas dit de quoi
il retournera demain mais il nous a dit
pourquoi le président parler à 13h on
écoute
il fait d'abord le choix d'être
interviewé et de pas faire une
allocution ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
contradicteur en face de lui ensuite il
fait le choix symbolique du 13h dont on
dit que ce sont les journaux des
territoires pour parler au maximum de
français et il le fera de manière
évidemment solennelle puisqu'il le fera
depuis l'Élysée l'idée c'est donc de
s'adresser aux Français des territoires
qu'on appelait naguère la province jadis
les régions ça a changé non on pourrait
aussi parler de France périphérique
comme dit christabilise ce qui serait
assez logique puisque c'est dans les
villes moyennes de la France
périphérique où la mobilisation était la
plus forte comme c'était déjà le cas
auparavant d'ailleurs pour le mouvement
des gilets jaunes donc reste à savoir ce
que Emmanuel Macron va nous dire alors
idéalement pour que son propos est un
impact très fort sur le pignon il
faudrait qu'on regarde demain à 13h et
qu'on se dise
qu'a dit le président parce que
c'est le cri qu'on est censé pousser
quand on a quelqu'un dit vraiment un
truc incroyable sauf que demain on ne
voit pas trop ce que le président Macron
pourrait vraiment dire
d'incroyable alors si c'est sûr que pour
obtenir l'effet waouh maximum il
faudrait retirer le projet de réforme
des retraites alors là tout le monde
dirait waouh vous avez vu il a retiré le
projet des retraites sauf que ce matin
et bien du stop lui était sur Sud Radio
et apparemment on ne prend pas le chemin
du retrait on l'écoute
la première ministre réalisable à
Elisabeth borne a annoncé qu'elle
saisissait elle-même pour que les
vérifications classiques soient faites
une fois que le Conseil constitutionnel
ce sera prononcé la loi entrera en
vigueur à partir du 1er septembre 203
alors autre effet possible je réfléchis
en même temps je dis oui l'autre effet
garantie waouh ça serait on change de
Première ministre sauf que là on n'y
croit pas non plus puisque regardez ce
matin Elisabeth borne continue à
s'attache de Premier ministre comme si
de rien n'était il était devant les
députés de la majorité donc on la voit
pardon ici qui sourit est applaudit
parlent de victoire pour le vote à
l'assemblée et puis cet après-midi elle
était à la tribune et vous allez voir
que elle était très compatible face à
l'opposition on l'écoute madame la
Présidente pano avec votre groupe vous
êtes des représentants de la nation
alors respectez le résultat des urnes et
les votes au Parlement respecter nos
institutions et respecter enfin notre
démocratie
alors que reste-t-il comme pis pour un
effet wow si on veut vraiment explorer
toutes toutes les pistes absolument tout
pourquoi pas la dissolution bon mais là
en même temps quand on regarde les
sondages on se dit est-ce que c'est
vraiment le moment quand on est tombé à
28% de popularité ce qui est le seuil le
plus bas plus les gilets jaunes de
demander aux Français de vous offrir une
majorité je ne pense pas personnellement
bon si vous me demandez mon avis demain
je pense que le président voudra
surmonter la crise des retraites qui
sont des objectifs vers le lointain les
objectifs pour plus tard mais faudrait
un grand projet qui a un effet waouh
alors ça bon en tout cas rien rien à
court terme à vous écouter Stéphane
merci merci beaucoup on va on va revenir
sur le statu quo qui semble l'option
présidentielle ce soir de ce qu'on
connaît des des différentes fuites de
participants aux réunions à l'Élysée
aujourd'hui mais je voudrais commencer
avec vous Dominique Rousseau parce qu'on
entend tout depuis cette cette séquence
cette crise sur les retraites crises
politiques crise institutionnelle ou
même crise de régime
quel est votre regard alors
effectivement c'est toujours difficile
de qualifier de qualifier une situation
je pencherai pour la crise de régime la
crise politique c'est classique un
gouvernement IR renversé il est remplacé
par un autre gouvernement bon crise
politique crise de régime c'est lorsque
le principe sur lequel nos institutions
fonctionnent
s'affaisse le principe sur lequel on
fonctionnait jusqu'à présent c'est si
l'avait énoncé le monopole de la
fabrication de la loi aux élus et les
citoyens se taisent ils attendent
l'élection l'élection prochaine or ce
principe est en train de s'affaiblir et
monte un autre principe le principe
selon lequel les citoyens seraient
associés il remplacerait par les élus
mais il serait associé à la fabrication
de la loi et on est dans une crime de
dans une crise de régime lorsque le
principe qui fait tenir le régime
s'affaiblit
la vie des citoyens pour l'instant on
n'est pas dans une idée de participation
de référendum il le demande mais voilà
il y a pas de représentants du
gouvernement ni et de la majorité sont
tous à l'Élysée ce soir mais ils vous
dirait c'est un outil démocratique à
partir du moment où il est légal
puisqu'il est prévu par la Constitution
il y a une forme de banalisation du 49-3
dans la bouche des membres du
gouvernement depuis quelques jours c'est
la centième fois qu'on l'utilise ils ont
tort de dire ça le 49 3 a été pensé en
1958 à la demande d'ailleurs des
premiers ministres on disait président
du conseil à l'époque de la Quatrième
République pour rationaliser le régime
parlementaire mais il a été pensé en
comment dire pour absence de majorité or
là Emmanuel Macron avait une majorité
puisque le texte a été élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire il y avait
une majorité il y avait une majorité au
Sénat il y avait des moments
fragile à l'Assemblée nationale ah je
pense que
mais la révision constitutionnelle
va être rejeté oui mais parfois on peut
on peut se tromper à quelques voix près
n'oubliez pas que la révision de 2008
elle a été adoptée à une voix très et
encore parce que le président de
l'Assemblée nationale contrairement à la
tradition à voter c'est votre regard
que vous dites parce que vous dites
finalement on est dans une crise de
régime car les français demandent à
participer à l'élaboration de la loi
mais est-ce que la bonne question c'est
pas de savoir pourquoi les Français
veulent participer à l'élaboration de la
loi c'est parce que il y a eu un
dysfonctionnement grave des institutions
il y a une dysfonctionnement grave du
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée du
fonctionnement du Sénat par
l'utilisation par le gouvernement de
procédure législatives qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la réforme des retraites et là
vous parlez du 47.1 sur le temps de
contraintes l'utilisation même du projet
de loi de finance rectificative de la
sécurité sociale et à mon avis un
constitutionnel donc j'espère que le
Conseil constitutionnel va censurer
cette loi d'ailleurs ce serait pas en
parler un service rendu au président de
la République par pourquoi parce que le
PLFSS normalement intervient en fin
d'année il y a déjà donc eu un
déplacement dans le temps d'un projet de
loi de finance de sécurité sociale qui
intervient d'habitude en fin d'année
parce qu'il s'agit de boucler les
comptes et donc le temps de débat est
réduit sur un PLFSS parce que il doit
entrer en application au 1er janvier
donc on a plusieurs dysfonctionnements
institutionnels se déplacement vers le
début d'année d'appel FSS l'intégration
d'une réforme très lourde qui n'a rien à
voir avec le PLFSS et compris donc pour
vous on va peut-être vers voilà donc les
gens qui ont vu ça effectivement ils
demandent à participer à la loi
c'est-à-dire maintenant il demande un
référendum d'initiative partagée parce
que ils ont été privés d'un
fonctionnement démocratique correct des
institutions
on verra parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
conditions il faut 4 millions et demi de
signatures on y est pas mais c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre regard crise
de régime parce que les citoyens veulent
participer ce qui dénature je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde sera d'accord sur
ce plateau Carl Barjon non vous levez
les yeux au ciel avant de venir à ce qui
peut dire demain non mais c'est vrai que
je ne suis pas spécialiste mais
la constitutionnalisme mais honnêtement
pour moi la crise de régime c'est quand
la police ne fonctionne plus quand
l'armée se mutine
voilà enfin que toutes les institutions
tombent
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'on en soit
là pour moi c'est une crise politique
grave
qui peut avoir aussi comme origine une
crise institutionnelle parce que c'est
vrai que les Français ont moins
confiance dans leurs institutions
qu'auparavant deux tiers des frelage du
49-3 qui était au fond utilisé enfin
c'est banal enfin on sait que Rocard
Michel Rocard l'avait utilisé de
nombreuses fois pas probablement l'usage
du cadence 9-3 passe moins bien
maintenant mais l'origine de tout ça
c'est quand même le fait que Manuel
Macron a une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée et qu'il n'a pas gagné enfin
il a pas eu la majorité il apparaît seul
contre
c'est vrai que vous avez une
superposition de d'utilisation de
procédures qui ont raccourci les débats
etc et à la fin le 49-3 tout ça
n'arrange rien mais pour moi je voudrais
qu'on essaie de se projeter sur ce qui
peut se passer demain avec cette
allocution ou plutôt cette interview
attendu du président qui sort du silence
ça va être compliqué de gouverner dans
ces conditions je crois que tout le
monde le sent que ce gouvernement étant
sursis et pourtant Rafa Legendre le
président semble ne pas vouloir changer
d'équipe au moins à court terme comment
l'expliquer c'est ce qu'on entend en
tout cas ce soir effectivement je pense
que la priorité d'Emmanuel Macron va
être précisément d'expliquer qu'il n'y a
pas de crise de régime pourquoi parce
que ce régime est protégé par les
institutions et notamment par la
Constitution qui offre tous les outils
nécessaires à un président de la
République pour faire avancer fustile au
forceps les réformes qui souhaitent
imposer c'était dans son programme
ces trois options au président de la
République c'était la dissolution
saignette le remaniement saignette en
tout cas pour l'instant pas question de
remanier sous la pression Emmanuel
Macron à horreur d'agir sur une réagir
sous la pression et pas de référendum
non plus effectivement donc le message
probablement adressé au chef de l'État
demain à la nation va être de tempérer
d'enjamber peut-être les péripéties
actuelles restent à voir ce qui se passe
dans la rue la réaction les blocages
est-ce que les pénuries d'essence
notamment qui sont très impactant dans
l'opinion publique vont continuer se
développer est-ce qu'on bloque le pays à
cause de ce passage au forccept au 49.3
il faudra qu'il tout à la fois qui qu'il
soit à l'écoute des français tout en
expliquant qu'il imposera tout de même
ses réformes c'est un peu un grand écart
d'après vos infos qu'est-ce qu'il
pourrait dire on entend récit déjà se
mettre en route dans la majorité le
président se sacrifie sa popularité sur
l'hôtel de l'intérêt général
l'opposition bruyante démagogique
irresponsable c'est ça qu'il va dire
demain il est fort probable que demain
il vous parliez de tempérer moi je pense
qu'il va appeler ce que c'est que
l'ordre d'une certaine manière l'ordre
contre le chaos il me semble que la
forme choisie par l'interview nous donne
un indication très forte sur le fond de
ce qui va raconter il va s'adresser dans
un trésor dans deux trésors les deux 13
heures principaux des chaînes de télé
française l'âge moyen du 13h c'est entre
56 et 60 ans et c'est un âge qui se
décale de plus en plus donc en fait il
s'adresse à qui ça reste quand même
principalement à des gens qui sont déjà
quasiment retraités à une tranche de la
population qui d'ailleurs était plutôt
plutôt d'accord avec le fait de faire
une réforme des retraites et donc il
s'adresse à des gens qui sont peut-être
un peu plus d'accord que les autres avec
lui
ça brûle un peu un peu partout mais avec
moi et ben on va jusqu'au bout c'est
pour le bien de la nation c'est parce
que c'est pour nos comptes l'équilibre
et l'ordre donc tout ça pour vous ne
doit rien au hasard il cible en
communication pour solder le dossier il
aurait fait peut-être une grande
conférence de presse aussi
le faire il dit l'Élysée laisse entendre
que il sera devant des journalistes donc
ce seront des contradicteurs enfin
pardon excusez-moi mais s'il avait
vraiment voulu avoir des contradicteurs
relativement punchy il aurait pas choisi
le 13h ce sont sans forcément être
méchant avec mes copains voilà donc
c'est quand même il y a quand même un
moment où le fond nous éclaire sur la
forme et si je peux juste rebondir ce
que disait tout à l'heure Dominique il
me semble qu'on est dans une crise
institutionnelle de la manière dont nos
institutions fonctionnent on est dans
une incapacité collective à trouver des
solutions et pas que sur la question des
retraites sur plein de dossiers de se
mettre autour d'une table et de trouver
des solutions pour réformer le pays
c'est quand même assez flagrant de se
rendre compte pour revenir
ne permet pas de trouver des compromis
j'aimerais bien qu'on aille aller les
après juste un point je parle de crise
de régime lorsque le sens philosophique
et lorsque le principe du gouvernement
qui est de laisser aux élus seul le
monopole de la production des lois est
remise en cause à ce moment-là les gens
ne croient plus quel que soit la loi
quelque soit les élus ne croient plus
aux lois qui ont été votées il y a un
autre principe qui depuis déjà plusieurs
années émergent qui est celui d'être
associé à la fabrication de la loi et là
on passe d'un régime à un autre sur le
point de l'histoire si Emmanuel Macron
effectivement ne dit rien ni dissolution
ni référendum ni remaniement si on
regarde ce qui s'est passé dans dans
l'histoire récente quand il y a eu
l'affaire du CPE le CPE était adopté par
49-3 le CP le CPE a été validé café
Jacques Chirac il a promulgué il a dit
je n'appliquerai pas la loi sur les CPE
quand de Gaulle en mai 68 sans comparer
avec évidemment mes 68 mais il fait une
réponse c'est à dire la première fois il
parle il dit rien tout le monde s'en
fout et après le 30 mai il dit jeudi
sous autrement dit il faut savoir quelle
est la situation actuelle si c'est pour
dire l'ordre etc ne vous inquiétez pas
ça va aller je pense que c'est pas une
réponse qui correspond me semble-t-il à
la situation est-ce que cette
communication la vraie question c'est
pas de savoir comment les dirigeants
s'en sortent mais c'est comment le pays
s'en sort parce qu'on est une vraie
souffrance c'est une vraie citoyen soit
associée c'est une vraie souffrance de
voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
France comment est-ce qu'on peut nous
abîmer nous faire mal c'est un pays
c'est comme une famille on a il faut
absolument on attend des dirigeants du
bien-être on attend des dirigeants
d'être mobilisés sur du positif on
attend des dirigeants d'avoir un horizon
vers lequel on se dit est-ce que vous
expliquer dans votre livre on y
reviendra vous voyez et donc vous
demandez le retrait de la réforme ce
soir au Président c'est bien clair pour
vous il faut la retirer
c'est évident
est-ce que démocratique est-ce que les
troupes vont soutenir la communication
présidentielle Elisabeth borne
d'ailleurs à la mi-journée a même dit au
députés macronistes que le rejet de la
motion de censure pouvait être une
victoire et les autoriser à utiliser ce
mot Elsa elles avouent qu'il y a de
place Beauvau la Réunion vient de
commencer à l'Élysée dans quel état
d'esprit arrive les députés de la
majorité
bien écoutez il y en a beaucoup Myriam
qui sont quand même content que le
président les reçoit et s'exprime
puisqu'ils sont dans un moment de
confusion on le rappelle une grande
partie des députés de la majorité
voulait aller au vote et beaucoup ont
été bien médusés par le résultat hier
une émotion de censure qui échoue à neuf
voix près alors effectivement maintenant
il le savent vous l'avez dit un
président de la République ne devrait
pas faire d'annonce puisqu'il a déjà dit
ni dissolution ni remaniement ni
référendum pour le moment un député
décrypte de toute façon il ne réagira
pas sous la pression un autre député me
disait tout à l'heure attendre un geste
d'apaisement sans pour autant pouvoir
dire lequel au sein du groupe
Renaissance il y a des attentes il y a
aussi des doutes un député espère enfin
une prise de conscience de l'exécutif
devant l'impasse qu'il qualifie d'un pas
et puis il y a aussi les partenaires le
modem et horizon pour qui clairement un
changement de méthode n'est pas
suffisant et puis bah c'est
parlementaire ils veulent savoir à quoi
ils vont servir on annonce moins de loi
plus de règlementaires ils veulent donc
connaître un peu l'agenda des prochaines
réformes et ils Adorne alors qu'on a vu
soutenu applaudi aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée par par les siens est-ce
qu'elle est vraiment soutenue
écoutez comment résumer la situation à
un député me disait est-ce qu'elle peut
rester non est-ce que son départ est
suffisant non évidemment il le savent
tous Élisabeth borne elle est très
fragilisée mais cependant ils disent
tous voilà ce qu'ils veulent c'est un
changement de cap un cap clair et pas
seulement changer une figure un
remaniement tout s'y pense évidemment en
disant qu'il faut faire de la place aux
politiques fini la société civile il
nous faut des ministres beaucoup plus
politiques merci beaucoup Elsa
mandingava évidemment si vous avez des
éléments nous provenant de cette réunion
on vous donnera la parole à nouveau en
direct Raphaël Legendre si je comprends
bien on fait le dos rond en attendant
que ça passe ma jambe comme il a
l'habitude de le faire assez souvent le
président de la République un il
temporise effectivement
à sa main la violence éventuellement
remplacée parce qu'on dit toujours il
n'aime pas la pression et le mettre des
horloges mais est-ce que il a les
candidats un Bruno Le Maire un Gérald
Darmanin est-ce que c'est si facile que
ça il y a des prétendants toujours pour
le pouvoir bien sûr est-ce que le
Président de la République a avoir
quelqu'un a envie d'avoir quelqu'un à
Matignon qui est une vraie surface
politique qui est une tête qui dépasse
il l'a expérimenté au début de son
précédent quinquennat il a vite couper
la tête
en tout cas depuis on a plutôt ce qui
s'apparente à des collaborateurs très
clairement et il aime plutôt fonctionné
comme ça il va falloir trouver quand
même un accord politique quand même plus
large
l'Allier c'est la droite ou ce qu'il
reste d'une droite capable de travailler
avec lui à Rachida Dati tiens qui
propose un accord de majorité de
gouvernement c'est quoi c'est apprendre
au sérieux comme Nicolas Sarkozy je
préconise depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois et même depuis la fin de
l'élection présidentielle
ça peut être une solution mais il faut
élargir de toute façon mais ça peut être
une solution c'est à dire compte tenu de
ce qui reste de LR aujourd'hui qui est
quand même sort de toute cette affaire
très abîmée après tout il peut y avoir
une moitié d'entre eux qui passent qui
serait d'accord peut-être pour passer un
accord en bonnet du forme avec le le
chef de l'État parce que ça avait quand
Nicolas Sarkozy avait dit ça vous vous
souvenez que on avait compris que Macron
voilà Macron a préféré les débauchages
individuels
justement de gouvernement de créer un
accord de gouvernement à l'Allemand avec
une partie de la droite ça peut ça peut
être une solution alors un moyen terme
parce que là je pense que demain cette
semaine c'est pas tout à fait le
comprendre un accord de gouvernement ça
voudrait dire qu'en amont on se met
d'accord sur un agenda de réforme très
précis c'est ça oui bien sûr mais ça
veut dire aussi qu'on est pas maître du
jeu avec qui la confiance est rompue
avec la droite quand même à droite ils
sont quand même fait balader pendant
plusieurs semaines
erikiotti n'a pas n'avait pas la
capacité ou n'a pas su tenir ses troupes
et à la fin on se retrouve avec
l'hésitation de vote ou pas votre et
puis au final pas de vote donc il n'y a
plus d'allier en dehors de de sa famille
politique aujourd'hui totalement isolée
et à gauche et à droite plus personne ne
veut aller vers un Emmanuel Macron de
toute façon de se représente pas en 2027
donc c'est un problème depuis le début
du quinquennat ensuite à droite la
poutre continue de travailler comme
disait Edouard Philippe il y a eu pas
plus tard que ce matin même un petit
déjeuner du conseil stratégique des LR
ou certains ont poussé on plaidait vous
avez cité Rachida Dati Jean-François
Copé également en plaid pour un accord
de gouvernement effectivement puisqu'ils
se revoit la dernière chance de la
droite de faire un peu le coucou c'est à
dire d'essayer de se rapprocher des
macronistes pour retrouver un peu de
pouvoir au sein de la macronie sachant
très bien qu'il manuel Macron ne pourra
pas se survivre et je vous donne la
parole elle est pour vous juste après
sur l'avenir de cette réforme des
retraites a priori la motion de censure
rejeter la réforme est adoptée mais
c'est pas si simple que ça puisque le
texte va désormais aller sur le bureau
de Laurent Fabius le président du
Conseil constitutionnel les 9 sages
vont-ils censurer tout ou partie du
texte élément de réponse avec Marion
Becker
c'est la dernière cartouche des
oppositions elle la saisine du Conseil
constitutionnel et des irres les députés
du rassemblement national ont saisi les
sages très effectivement de clôturer
cette séquence des astreuses et de
montrer que ce projet de réforme des
retraites n'était pas préparé qu'il
était bancal qu'il a été mal présenté
aux Français et qui avait des vis de
forme entre le passage de la réforme
dans un projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale l'utilisation
d'outils d'urgence ou la limitation du
temps des débats autant de procédures
que les parlementaires de gauche
dénoncent eux aussi ont déposé un
recours moi j'attends qu'il fasse son
travail sereinement sans pression bien
sûr et de façon la plus objective
possible ça veut dire qu'ils disent le
droit on espère le maximum du Conseil
constitutionnel parce qu'en fait de bout
en bout cette loi résulte des fractions
démocratiques dans la majorité on ne
veut pas croire à une censure globale le
texte c'est un sujet qui a été
évidemment
regardé par avance on regarde toujours
la constitutionnalité d'une loi donc on
verra bien d'ailleurs le gouvernement
lui-même saisit le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a des sujets qui
peuvent être mis en débat ils ont été
mis en débat avant on voit bien lesquels
mais le cœur de la réforme ne semble pas
je me tromper j'ai pas le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le cœur de la
réforme ne semble pas mise en danger
reste la censure partielle le Conseil
constitutionnel peut retoquer seul
quelques mesures il va aussi devoir se
prononcer sur la recevabilité de la
demande de référendum d'initiative
partagée par la gauche il a un mois pour
statuer alors Dominique Rousseau le cœur
du texte n'est pas en danger c'est ce
que Dirick verte d'accord ou pas le cœur
le cœur non en revanche la manière dont
la loi a été votée là certainement un
risque réel de de censure
pour expliquer clairement les choses si
la procédure le véhicule législatif
l'employé et censuré c'est tout le texte
qui tombe le Conseil pourrait dire
pourraient dire en quelque sorte au
gouvernement écoutez vous pouvez passer
de 60 à 64 ça j'ai rien à dire là-dessus
en revanche la manière dont vous l'avez
passé c'est-à-dire par le 47,3 et en
portant atteinte alors je cite le
conseil en portant atteinte de manière
manifeste au principe de sincérité de
clarté des débats parlementaires nous
conduit à censurer à censurer donc on
regarde plus le fond on regarde que le
véhicule est donc la forme ça fait tout
tomber on regarde pas le fond on regarde
on regarde la procédure c'est pour ça
qu'on vous disiez tout à l'heure
enjamber je veux dire attention avant
d'enjamber il y a il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel et si le Conseil
constitutionnel censure et bien la loi
ne peut pas être promulguée et les
compteurs sont remis à zéro et on repart
avec une loi ordinaire comme ça c'est
fait avec la loi qui avait lancé Édouard
Philippe ou Marisol Touraine ou Edwards
Fabius soit le président du Conseil
constitutionnel on fait que du droit où
il y a un peu de politique on fait que
du droit c'est pour ça que je ne vois
pas comment le Conseil constitutionnel
peut ne pas censurer moi je suis
convaincu que la loi va être attendez
non non pour des raisons juridiques j'ai
quatre mandats à l'Assemblée nationale
donc je connais un petit peu un petit
peu le droit constitutionnel et l'usage
du cavalier du projet de loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale est
inconstitutionnel l'accumulation de
l'usage de toutes les règlements de
l'Assemblée nationale on l'a vu le 47,3
etc qui a pour objectif de réduire
le temps de débat parlementaire est
inconstitutionnel et le Conseil
constitutionnel et le gardien du bon
fonctionnement des institutions et de la
conformité des lois à la Constitution on
engage pas une réforme de cette
importance qui touche aussi profondément
les Français l'histoire de France par
rapport à la sécurité sociale
en utilisant des voyelles des Raphaël
instruments législatifs en fait et
juridique qui ne sont pas conformes
c'est une part de sortie pour vous
c'est peut-être pour le gouvernement
j'entendais pour le président de la
République qui le Conseil censure la loi
je veux dire
ça respire il y en a un apaisement et là
je me mettais dans la peau du
il y aura beaucoup d'ironie sur
l'amateurisme Raphaël bah bien sûr
budgétaire du financement de la sécurité
sociale est un texte qui doit corriger
les finances de la sécurité sociale dans
l'année pas forcément en fin des
collectifs budgétaires on peut en avoir
tout au long de l'année dès que la
trajectoire annuelle est modifiée
excusez-moi il se trouve juste sur ce
point-là pourquoi est-ce que les débats
d'appel FSS sont restreints c'est pour
avoir la certitude que c'est voté avant
la fin de l'année donc vous voyez que
déplacer un pelle FSS en début d'année
mais il peut y en avoir plusieurs tout
au long de l'année on en aura en fin
d'année
de ce véhicule cette année de la
sécurité sociale vont changer en réalité
dès le mois de septembre sur notamment
le versement du myco du minimum
contributif les 1200 les fameux 1200
euros par mois sur lesquels on attend
des battues et donc en termes de droit
simplement pour dire le droit au Conseil
constitutionnel a priori le véhicule
législatif du PLFSS R et tout à fait
légitime d'accord
c'est dans un mois au maximum on imagine
que voilà c'est pas le scénario que
souhaite le gouvernement je voudrais
vous emmener pour terminer ce débat sur
l'agenda des réformes est-ce que le
quinquennat est à l'arrêt est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron est condamné à
l'impuissance il aurait dit selon des
participants cette phrase il plaide le
président de la République pour un
changement de méthode et d'agenda des
réformes il faudra réformer avec moins
de loi et plus de réglementaires
j'aurais mis Baudot au contournerait le
Parlement alors pour tenir le mieux
placé pour avoir un avis définitif sur
la question purement institutionnelle
mais il y a la question de la forme il y
a la question du fond et effectivement
peut-être que là encore il essaie de se
servir du fond pour enfin de la forme et
du fond de manière concomonde il sait
qu'il veut faire travailler la question
des de l'immigration
qu'elle n'y allait pas donc le texte à
la poubelle d'un point de vue
législatifs effectivement il y a un
certain nombre de textes que la macronie
a dans sa besace et que pour l'instant
on a du mal à voir sur quel genre de
texte elle va pouvoir passer en fait
quel est le projet alternatif et lui il
est lisait dit d'une certaine manière il
va falloir passer à autre chose le temps
le temps des retraites c'est terminé
voilà passons à autre chose mais un
est-ce qu'il est en capacité de le faire
à l'Assemblée est-ce que la majorité
politique pour le faire est-ce que les
Français sont prêts à le faire est-ce
que les syndicats sont prêts à le faire
est-ce que demain ils vont pouvoir se
remettre autour de la table prenez un
Laurent Berger si c'est Emmanuel Macron
fait un grand CNR et Laurent Berger il
ne vient pas donc il y a aussi un moment
où le temps et c'est peut-être ce qui va
se jouer demain aussi gagner du temps à
travers cette interview de 13h il va
avoir besoin de temps pour remobiliser
tout le monde la roll Barjon la phrase
que vous avez cité là d'Emmanuel Macron
à l'instant encore une fois prudence
proposé
la même chose à midi un président de
groupe Mali la même chose et donc ce
qu'on comprend c'est que au des sujets
qui peuvent être traités effectivement
une réflexion sur le travail l'École etc
bon on peut faire des choses sans passer
par la loi c'est ça qui veut dire il y a
un problème de de méthode et il y a
enfin comment dire Macron a quand même
souligné finalement que on ne faisait
pas assez attention au parlementaire et
donc il y avait d'une certaine façon
enfin c'est ce que j'ai compris
voilà une petite remise en cause
de la présidente du groupe peut-être
même du ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement si on peut pas garantir une
majorité à l'Assemblée on fera sur le
Parlement c'est ça qui va danser il y a
il y a un peu de sort c'est à dire on
peut aussi gouverner par décret quoi une
troisième voie possible qui est parce
qu'effectivement passer vers plus de
réglementaires à un moment où on a un
désir de démocratie de participation du
peuple qui s'exprime très clairement
nombreuses reprises que les lois étaient
probable en France
c'est que les ministres travaillent
beaucoup plus en amont avec les
parlementaires pour verrouiller les
majorités
de méthodologie le problème c'est une
question de fond quelles sont les bonnes
réformes et quelles sont les mauvaises
réformes si on continue à faire des
mauvaises réformes que ce soit la loi le
règlement ça change pas grand chose ce
qu'il faut se faire le bon réformes qui
remette le pays d'aplomb qui donne le
français de se réengager à nouveau dans
l'action qui donne aux jeunes d'espérer
et qui donne une perspective au pays
c'est ça qui nous manque cruellement
aujourd'hui même sans majorité c'est
possible vous pensez que c'est encore
possible mais la majorité elle sera
semble autour des idées positives et des
actions positives donc il faut faire
confiance à cette assemblée des réformes
qui qui font souffrir 80% des Français
c'est impossible on y vient directement
allez on va parler de la cruauté du
monde vous nous y emmenez c'est Golan
Royal merci merci pour ce décryptage le
jour d'avant l'intervention
présidentielle on verra ce qu'il en est
demain merci à vous vous restez avec moi
Ségolène Royal dans une dizaine de
minutes tout juste les parties pris de
nos affranchis sont déjà prêts
feniginochet vous la voyez pour
l'économie qui va dresser le bilan de la
prime Macron un peu passé sous les sous
les radars il faut le dire Isabelle
Lasserre qui va revenir sur la rencontre
chez giping Poutine à Moscou et puis
Bourbon Express c'est Thibault et Nox ce
soir qui va nous parler justement de
cette réunion des républicains les
républicains en pleine décomposition
mais on plonge d'abord dans votre livre
refuser la cruauté du monde aux éditions
du Rocher le temps d'aimer est venu
c'est tout un programme ça mérite
quelques explications on voit cela dans
l'invitation de Mario Becker et on en
parle juste après
si on vous invite Ségolène Royal c'est
pour votre dernier ouvrage refusez l'a
cruauté du monde le temps est venu
d'aimer dites-vous l'amour c'est le fil
directeur de votre pensée vous savez une
nation un peuple c'est comme une famille
c'est comme une famille pour faire
grandir une famille qu'elle soit
heureuse qu'elle s'épanouissent qu'elle
conquiert son autonomie il faut de
l'amour il faut un projet il faut
l'encourager sauf que la justice
c'est un peu votre marque de fabrique en
2007 candidate à la présidentielle puis
en 2008 vous inquiétez déjà la
solidarité
[Applaudissements]
20 ans plus tôt déjà conseillère à
l'Élysée le discours se dessine jamais
autant qu'aujourd'hui les différentes
générations dans eu autant besoin les
unes des autres depuis vous avez exercé
presque tous les mandats députés
présidente de région et surtout ministre
quatre fois sous François Mitterrand
Jacques Chirac puis François Hollande
vous vous êtes souvent livré sur votre
parcours aujourd'hui après plus de 30
ans de vie politique vous vous sentez le
devoir de témoigner
30 ans pendant lesquels vous avez vu
s'effondrer dites-vous le lien entre le
peuple et ses dirigeants alors vous les
enjoignez à reconquérir le cœur du
peuple c'en est presque un manuel de
développement personnel à destination
des politiques il n'est pas dirigé
contre le pouvoir en place assurez-vous
et pourtant il n'y a rien d'amical dans
votre analyse de la gestion du covid des
gilets jaunes des retraites de la guerre
en Ukraine ou encore de l'urgence
écologique le pouvoir pousse le peuple à
bout le précarise ce sont vos propres
mots vous pointez également l’égo
surdimensionnés des politiques un homme
politique est toujours tenté de se
gonfler d'orgueil péché originel de la
politique
conséquences inévitable de la
médiatisation
alors on vous pose la question Ségolène
Royal n'êtes-vous pas vous-même visé par
cette critique
réponse mais au moins je suis dans
l'autocritique parce que je sais et j'ai
vu les dégâts que peut provoquer l'ego
mais regarde aujourd'hui
la question c'est pas de savoir si
bien l'intérêt général sauver le système
des retraites
c'était pas du tout le résultat de cette
réforme c'était pas de sauver le système
des retraites il y a pas de déficit on
le sait alors
pour lutter contre les déficitifs aussi
remettre l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune donc l'argumentaire qui consiste
à dire qu'il sera sans doute développé
demain en disant malgré vous je vais
faire votre bien malgré vous moi je sais
ce qui est bon pour vous comment il est
né ce livre il est né ce livre il est
une visite en EHPAD avant le confinement
et de l'effondrement des tendresse
pendant le confinement et je me suis
demandé mais comment est-ce que un
pouvoir politique
était devenu aussi cruel à l'égard des
citoyens sans avoir la capacité
finalement d'écouter avec des qu'on a
tous subis de façon en état en situation
de sidération l'interdiction des sorties
l'interdiction des librairies les
enfants au milieu des ronds dans les
cours d'école on a on a subi on a été
décérés après c'était vraiment des
aberrations
extravagantes et il y a pas eu de soins
ni de consolation ni de réparation et
malgré cela il y a eu donc en plus des
réformes brutales sur le modèle social
et donc la question centrale c'est de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on gouverne
bien au gouverne bien quand on a l'amour
du peuple qu'on a en responsabilité vous
voyez qu'on n'est pas obsédé par sa
posture sa réputation son avenir à soi
mais quand on est heureux dans
l'exercice du pouvoir et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui la vraie question que je me
pose en regardant ceux qui sont
responsabilités et en voyant les dégâts
de la France tel quel est aujourd'hui
les gens en grève les ordres qui
souffrent qui perdent du salaire qui ont
peur de leur avenir comment est-ce que
on peut être heureux en gouvernant un
pays et en le mettant dans cette
situation c'est pas possible alors que
si vous vous dites attendez comment
est-ce que je fais pour remettre le pays
d'aplomb pour que les gens soient
content de retourner au travail qui soit
au clair sur ce que c'est que le modèle
social français quand même que là vous
défendez la méthode royale celle que
vous c'est pas la méthode royale vous
vouliez mettre en place quand vous
disiez fraternité quand vous disiez
aimez-vous les uns les autres tout le
monde a encore cette phrase en tête il y
a quelque chose de presque religieux à
vous lire sur une forme de spiritualité
fraternité c'est dans de vise
républicaine donc pourquoi est-ce que on
gouverne pas avec plus de fraternité
par la peur et la menace objectivement
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce que vous
pourquoi est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y
a des millions de gens qui descendent
dans la rue c'est très difficile vous
avez de se mettre en grève de perdre du
salaire d'aller dans la rue de risquer
tout le monde
et qui est de plus en plus chaotique
d'imputer la responsabilité aux élus
politiques les raisons plus pour ne pas
en rajouter pourquoi détruire le modèle
social français on croirait entendre
Stéphane Hessel ça reste tellement
d'actualité
indignez-vous quand il dit mais comment
est-ce que l'État peut nous dire qu'il a
pas les moyens de sauver le les
protections sociales et même de les
améliorer alors que quand on les a mis
en place à la Libération il y avait
beaucoup moins d'argent qu'aujourd'hui
donc les riches sont toujours plus
riches les économies de votre vie a
quand même largement augmenté alors
pourquoi exactement donc si le niveau de
vie augmente pourquoi réduire les acquis
sociaux c'est complètement incohérent
puisque le pays est beaucoup plus riche
qu'avant et tout cela pourquoi pour les
marchés financiers d'ailleurs on l'a dit
on va sacrifier quoi mais ils n'auront
jamais assez les marchés
ne fait pas du bien aux Français s'il ne
s'aiment pas entre eux les politiques
alors ils ne peuvent pas nous aimer nous
c'est vrai elle a toujours existé cette
violence vous l'avez voilà vous l'avez
suivi parfois vous l'avez déclenché et
ça peut ça peut arriver sur des rapports
de force non pas avoir jamais déclenché
de la violence non je vous la violence
l'état dans lequel la politique est
aujourd'hui par sa façon de faire mais
elle a toujours existé François
Mitterrand etc il y a eu beaucoup de
violence oui oui mais je le fais pas
l'abstraction de ce qui se passe mais
aujourd'hui il y a une accumulation des
chocs on a la choc climatique regardez
il y a le rapport du GIEC aujourd'hui on
en a la jeunesse d'ailleurs
on a eu le choc de l'inflation on a le
choc de la guerre donc pourquoi rajouter
un choc supplémentaire dans la
destruction du modèle social français et
d'ailleurs si les jeunes descendent dans
la rue on pourrait s'étonner on pourrait
dire mais attendez c'est pas leur
problème des retraites mais si c'est
parce qu'ils ont compris que c'était un
modèle global qui était en cause et
qu'autour de cette question du modèle
français il y a pas de débat ce qui vous
désole aussi c'est la chute de la
natalité et cette génération pour partie
qui est vrai je ne veux pas avoir
d'enfant ce serait face au dérèglement
climatiques les mettre dans un monde que
je ne souhaite pas moi-même voilà c'est
une des raisons aussi de l'écriture de
l'amour on peut résoudre ce problème
mais en leur donnant qu'on sait pas un
peu naïf non pas du tout je crois que
c'est au contraire c'est très puissant
ce sont les fondamentaux même de
l'action publique c'est-à-dire quand on
a l'honneur d'avoir la responsabilité du
destin d'un peuple la moindre des choses
c'est de se dire mais comment je peux
rendre ce peuple heureux et en
particulier la nouvelle génération et
c'est vrai que quand j'entends des
jeunes dire aujourd'hui à quoi bon avoir
des enfants je m'interroge vraiment sur
ce que on a pu leur transmettre c'est à
dire si on n'est même plus capable de
transmettre le désir de transmettre la
vie alors c'est quelque chose de va pas
et qu'il faut le réparer et le
transformer une nation vous c'est comme
une famille un peuple c'est comme une
famille vous le disiez dans le sujet
qu'on a vu Emmanuel Macron est-il un bon
père de famille
un bon père de la nation pas pour
l'instant non je ne crois pas pourquoi
parce que les gens souffrent vous voyez
les gens souffrent les inégalités se
creusent donc une famille c'est quoi
c'est encouragé c'est aimer c'est
valorisé c'est donner envie d'avancer
c'est donner envie de grandir c'est pas
fracturé c'est pas brutalisé c'est pas
cruel c'est pas décidé tout seul sans
écouter la fratrie c'est pas avoir pensé
qu'on a raison tout seul alors ça c'est
drôle parce que ils sont pas les seuls
là vous parlez d'Emmanuel Macron mais la
verticalité du pouvoir d'isolement
l'autoritarisme aussi souvent partagée
par la classe politique vous avez voté
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à la dernière
présidentielle vous trouvez que c'est un
exemple d'ouverture de délibération et
de bienveillance moi je regarde ce que
les idées qui sont pas qui verrouillent
sont partis on a pu voir les récentes
polémiques le problème c'est pas la
gestion de la partie c'est pas la dans
un pays vous voyez donc la question
c'est de savoir quel regrettait pas du
quel mais non parce que je pense que
tout le monde aurait eu intérêt tous les
Français quel que soit leur opinion
politique sauf l’extrême droite aurait
eu intérêt à avoir le débat que nous
avons d'ailleurs là à l'instant
c'est-à-dire quel est le modèle français
est-ce qu'il faut pas se battre pour le
maintien des services publics pourquoi
obéir pourquoi obéir au marché financier
pourquoi obéir aux agences de notation
énormément aider les Français le quoi
qu'il en coûte ce gouvernement de quoi
qu'il en coûte
quand même le chômage partiel ça a été
quand même bien sûr 600 milliards de
dettes aujourd'hui c'est les Français
c'est l'argent des Français
l'argent n'est pas voilà une source mais
vous avez un tarissable c'est pour ça
que comme le dit d'ailleurs la
Constitution il faut que chacun
contribue en fonction de ses moyens donc
ce qui est aujourd'hui révolte les
Français c'est que d'un côté l'impôt de
solidarité sur la peau sur la fortune
financière a été supprimée ça suffirait
que que les dividendes
flamboyant bien sûr que ça suffirait
puisque vous lisez tout à l'heure la
France est beaucoup plus riche que la
libération donc c'est un problème de
répartition de cette richesse qui est en
cause de régresser sur les acquis
sociaux sur l'école sur la santé l'idée
c'est un choix idéologique et vous
développez sur la bienveillance sur la
fraternité sur la douceur aussi que les
femmes portent mieux
c'est voilà c'est c'est capacités là ces
qualités
gouvernaient le monde il serait plus
amusants ce qui est riche dans la
richesse qui d'une humanité c'est la
biodiversité humaine c'est le masculin
et le féminin donc c'est l'équilibre et
c'est vrai que quand vous voyez à
l'échelle planétaire que sur 180 chefs
de taille avec une dizaine de femmes ça
c'était un vrai problème voilà vous ne
j'en rêrais pas la manière de pouvoir
mais c'est l'équilibre et je pense que
si les les décisions étaient beaucoup
plus sanitaire à l'échelle du monde on
aurait pu longtemps régler la question
climatique puisque les femmes ont été
les premières à lancer les alertes on
aurait réglé peut-être davantage la
question du désarmement on aurait
peut-être anticipé et empêcher le
déclenchement des guerres alors
justement je pense qu'on est sur la
guerre parce que vous écrivez le monde
entier découvre médusés et en colère les
milliards qui arrivent pour les armes en
Ukraine alors qu'ils étaient
introuvables pour lutter contre le
désert trop climatique et la misère bien
sûr les aider les Ukrainiens
renverser la question je pense qu'il
faut aider tous ceux qui sont opprimés à
l'échelle à l'échelle du monde il y a
d'autres guerres mais alors est-ce que
ça n'existe pas ce genre de phrases là
ça ne clique pas il y a des Français qui
vont se dire mais moi je veux l'argent
pourquoi on le donne aux ocriniens non
je n'ai pas très empathie la question
est d'ailleurs c'est la suite du propos
c'est de dire il faut donc empêcher les
guerres on le savait puisque il devait y
avoir on le savait ça avait été dit
qu'il y aurait eu cette agression donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on avait anticipé
des armes sur les sur les frontières on
le savait c'est une guerre qui dure que
depuis 2014 donc il y a pas eu
d'anticipation de cette guerre et
d'autres puisque c'est l'ensemble des
guerres aussi qui sont intolérables
comme dit le Pape justement la totalité
des dépenses pour les armements c'est la
totalité de ce qu'il faut pour éduquer
pour soigner tous les enfants du monde
ça vaut pas la peine ça de s'engager
dans le désarmement et de la prévention
des guerres moi je crois que si bon ben
la politique c'est pas derrière vous
c'est je comprends bien pour terminer ça
gun royal et la vie c'est la vie la
politique elle est refuser la cruauté du
monde point d'exclamation vous l'aurez
compris dans le droit fil de Stéphane
Hessel le temps d'aimer est venu c'est à
dire aux éditions du Rocher Ségolène
Royal vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris vous ils vont vous faire
réagir et bien les accueillent tout de
suite bienvenus les affranchis n'hésitez
pas Isabelle Lasserre du Figaro qui va
revenir sur la rencontre chez ghipping
Poutine et Fanny guinochet de France
Info le décryptage éco du matin qui
revient sur la prime Macron dans un
premier bilan on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
vous allez vous allez nous dire ce qu'il
en est mais on commence comme chaque
soir avec Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce
soir par Thibault et knock bonsoir
Thibault bonsoir Myriam vous nous
racontez une histoire de frondeur c'est
ça
n'est-ce pas Ségolène Royal est bien il
y a désormais les frondeurs de la droite
la division couvert elle a éclaté au
grand jour hier 19 députés les
républicains ont donc voté la censure
contre le gouvernement vous les voyez 19
députés sur les 61 que compte le groupe
c'est près d'un tiers certains étaient
attendus comme le député Aurélien
Pradier et ses proches d'autres moins
ainsi trois députés proches de Laurent
Wauquiez ont voté la censure Myriam
alors comment la direction du parti a
réagi en deux temps d'abord hier soir
c'était un peu la sidération écoutez la
réaction du président du parti eriki au
sortir de l'hémicycle on connaissait la
méthode Coué bien la méthode ciottier
est assez proche
il y a 42 députés LR qui ont suivi notre
avis voilà c'est à dire une très large
majorité du groupe la censure n'a pas
été approuvée les républicains ont fait
peur œuvre de cohérence de
responsabilité alors voilà pour le
discours officiel est en coulisse
évidemment on parlait de crise ouverte
une réunion de crise a d'ailleurs eu
lieu aujourd'hui deux réunions pour
tenter de désamorcer la crise d'abord un
comité stratégique du parti ce matin et
puis un peu plus tard une réunion du
groupe ici à l'Assemblée nationale alors
que c'était dit y a-t-il eu des
règlements de compte pas tant que ça il
n'y a pas eu de pugilat nous a confié un
député mais on n'a pas mis non plus la
poussière sous le tapis concrètement
chacun s'est expliqué et au final il a
été décidé de ne pas sanctionner les
députés ayant voté la censure ne seront
pas exclus ce matin le président du
groupe les républicains Olivier Marleix
avait même un ton presque cajoler
je ne peux pas je peux pas en vouloir je
respecte les convictions de chacun de
mes collègues je peux pas leur en
vouloir je comprends parfaitement que je
n'ai pas envie d'assumer une réforme qui
a été malgré tout portée par Emmanuel
Macron un temps qui tranche avec celui
qui l'employait la semaine dernière pour
menacer ceux qui signeraient une motion
de censure petit extrait pour mémoire
que six signes a une motion avec l'iode
ils avaient vocation à l'ICG Elliot
voilà donc aussi simple que ça c'est la
responsabilité c'est leur choix alors
comment expliquer ce changement de ton
temps et bien justement par le nombre
des députés ayant voté finalement la
censure c'est un peu comme les banques
to big to fail pas de sanction parce que
cela aurait réduit le groupe à peau de
chagrin alors est-ce qu'il y a des
décisions qui ont été prises ou rien oui
on a acté quand même la nécessité d'un
changement de méthode il a essayé de
jouer plus collectif de préparer les
textes en amont tous ensemble en
revanche quand une position majoritaire
aura été dégagée bien ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord seront prier de se taire
c'est en substance qui a expliqué
Olivier Marleix aujourd'hui
il faut un peu plus de respect du
collectif pas normal que
des parlementaires qu'une position qui
n'est pas celle de la majorité de leurs
collègues aillent perturber on va dire
le message exprimé par notre famille
politique et que une fois que cette
position est celle du groupe elle soit
respectée et là que les jeux personnels
du coup ne soient plus ne soit plus
possible alors voilà pour la mise au
point du jour reste que la gêne était
manifeste aujourd'hui du côté des
républicains tout au long de la journée
on a fait profil bas les réactions côté
micro sont restées très discrètes
écoutez
le comité stratégique de votre partie
je n'ai qu'une chose à dire la poutre
travaille et va continuer à travailler
ça veut dire merci ça veut dire quoi
les frondeurs alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
dit ils ont réagi hors micro ils ont dit
ouf d'abord parce que c'est vrai que le
coupé le coup prêt quand même passé près
les voies demandant une réponse ferme et
une exclusion était nombreuse et puis
ils ont dit chiche ensuite chiche à
cette nouvelle méthode d'ailleurs
ont-ils renchéri c'est celle qui leur
aurait fallu appliquer dès le départ
plutôt que de négocier avec le
gouvernement sans nous avoir demandé
notre avis conclusion un avenir où ils
sont morts certains doutes que ils
puissent survivre à cet épisode ils nous
l'ont dit malgré cette thérapie groupe
et cette remise à plein une chose est
certaine en tout cas c'est que tout le
monde aimerait tourner au plus vite
cette page des retraites qui a fait tant
de dégâts merci beaucoup Thibault pour
ce groupe les frondeurs possèdent
parlementaires
une dizaine non 15 15 parlementaires
on verra ce qu'il en est on va vous
faire réagir sur cette prime Macron avec
Fanny guinochet donc Lindsey sortie une
enquête la fameuse prime Macron qui
permettait et bien de distribuer dans
les entreprises des primes avec des
cotisations en moins pour payer par
l'État pour exonérer de cotisation
est-ce que ça a marché quel bilan alors
quel bilan il y a quand même eu un tiers
des salariés français qui en ont
bénéficié 5 millions de d'employés ça
n'est pas rien et en moyenne ils ont
touché autour de 800 euros alors à un
moment où l'inflation donc ce sont des
chiffres de l'année dernière à un moment
où l'inflation a été élevée et ça met du
beurre dans les épines mais ce que
montre l'Insee c'est qu'en fait il y a
un effet de remplacement aussi attendait
mais là l'Insee le démonte en effet de
substitution à la place de véritables
hausse de salaire une partie en fait
et bien a été mangé par cette prime
Lindsay dit que c'est environ un tiers
ce qui veut dire que si vous avez eu 100
euros de prix mais bien en fait 30 euros
aurait dû être au moins des hausses de
salaire alors une prime c'est bien mais
rien ne dit que vous l'aurez l'année
suivante c'est un peu le problème or on
voit que 2023 va être encore une année
où l'inflation ou le coup de la vie va
être élevé donc si je vous entends bien
les salariés sont perdants avec ce
système de prime et bien oui alors ils
sont perdants à long terme déjà aussi
parce que cette prime est exonérée de
cotisations sociales et notamment pour
les retraites ça n'ouvre pas de droit à
la retraite alors on en parle beaucoup
en ce moment mais en plus on peut se
dire que c'est cotisations ça abonde
notre régime de retraite qui a quelques
difficultés financières en revanche ceux
qui sont gagnants ce sont évidemment les
employeurs parce qu'ils ont distribué du
pouvoir d'achat sans avoir beaucoup de
frais alors les petites entreprises
l'ont beaucoup fait mais pas que les
grandes aussi ont beaucoup utilisé le
dispositif et 2022 a été une bonne année
et oui alors justement quand on regarde
le CAC 40 on a entendu tous les records
les résultats que ce soit le luxe
l'énergie
dans tous les secteurs les banques il y
a eu des profits records c'était le
terme alors en plus interroger est-ce
que ces groupes qui avaient qui ont fait
d'énormes bénéfices l'année dernière en
plus ils sortaient de la crise covid où
ils ont bénéficié d'un certain nombre
d'aides d'État n'avait-il pas les moyens
de payer des hausses de faire des
hausses de salaire ou en tout cas de
donner des primes qui au moins soient
chargés c'est comme ça que les patronat
lui dit mais en tout cas et des
cotisations et paye aussi des impôts
pour ce que c'est autant d'argent de
perte d'argent pour financer notre
modèle social mais aussi pour Bercy
c'est une perte de création de richesse
et c'est pas c'est pas un petit montant
parce que en fait quand on regarde
l'Insee a calculé que il y avait eu 4
milliards et demi d'euros de primes
versées l'an dernier alors cette prime
elle est encore en cours on peut encore
distribuer cette prime jusqu'à fin
décembre un tout petit mot je vous
sentez
très très bonne analyse et d'ailleurs un
débat comme ça vous voyez devrait venir
à l'Assemblée nationale plutôt que
des débats de qui rendent les gens
malheureux parce que ça c'est le vrai
sujet c'est la question de la juste
répartition et des entreprises ont été
aidées qui n'en avaient absolument pas
besoin plus le manque à gagner fiscal
fait des hausses de système juste un mot
qu'on baisse les retraites pour 12
milliards enfin maintenant avec les tout
ce qui a été amendé pour 6 milliards
mais l'évasion fiscale c'est 100
milliards oui c'est ça aussi que les
gens voient maintenant ils comprennent
non les grands écarts allez on enchaîne
avec vous Isabelle vous vouliez revenir
sur le déplacement le premier
déplacement d'ailleurs depuis sa
réélection de chez zipping à Moscou qui
a rencontré donc le chef de Kremlin
Vladimir Poutine alors ils ont parlé
devinez quoi évidemment d'Ukraine parce
que sous une apparente neutralité en
fait la Chine depuis le début de la
guerre a choisi son camp et c'est bien
sûr celui de la Russie la Chine n'a pas
condamné l'invasion russe elle
n'applique pas les sanctions
occidentales et elle reprend la
propagande du Kremlin qui dit que c'est
l'Occident et l'OTAN qui ont en fait
attaqué l'Ukraine alors la Chine se
satisfait pour pour l'instant de la
guerre qui dure en Ukraine il peut
acheter des gros carbures à bas prix il
augmente la dépendance du Kremlin et
vis-à-vis de Pékin et il détourne aussi
l'attention des Américains de l'Asie
mais pourtant si j'ai une pique depuis
le début à de lignes rouges la première
ce c'est l'utilisation des armes
nucléaires tactiques et la deuxième
c'est l'effondrement du pouvoir russe
russe qui entraînerait probablement une
période de de chaos dans toute la région
et vis-à-vis du monde occidental et des
pays en développement la Chine essaye de
se présenter en ce moment comme une
puissance pacificatrice et une puissance
stabilisatrice c'est donc du fameux plan
de paix chinois
c'est bien sûr un plan qui est plutôt
favorable aux intérêts russes mais si
j'ai une ping essaye aujourd'hui de
rallier en fait ce qu'on appelle global
c'est-à-dire les non alignées alors la
relation est solide ça on peut le dire
la Russie en fait depuis le début de la
guerre cette relation n'a fait que se
renforcer contrairement à ce que penser
les Européens et les Français en tête
qui pensaient au début de la guerre
essayez de séparer la Russie et la Chine
et essayer de convaincre la Chine de
faire une pression suffisante sur
Vladimir Poutine pour le faire reculer
en Ukraine les pays encore de nombreuses
divergences par exemple dans leur
volonté de changer l'ordre mondial
Vladimir Poutine veut l'incendier le
maître complètement par terre alors que
si j'ai une ping lui essaye de le
transformer plus doucement de
l'intérieur par les organisations des
Nations unies par exemple mais les deux
régimes ont en commun une chose c'est la
haine de l'Occident la haine des
États-Unis et de l'Europe et ça
l'emporte sur tous les sujets l'un comme
l'autre veulent mettre fin à la
domination
occidentale sur le monde et ils veulent
faire qui ont fait leur modèle
autocratique qui en fait est une
détestation de la démocratie et qui fait
peu de cas des droits humains cette
fameuse guerre entre le sud global et
l'Occident cette cette alliance
objective c'est au détriment
de l'Occident parce qu'on voit c'est
incroyable histoire est en train de se
faire sous nos yeux on voit la
constitution de deux blocs qui ont l'air
de plus en plus solide avec d'un côté le
bloc autocrate Chine Russie qui a été
rejoint par l'Iran et puis d'un côté les
États-Unis et l'Europe qui eux
soutiennent l'Ukraine et qui l'Ukraine
et qui savent qu'une défaite en fait de
Kiev les les affaibliraient alors en
fait tout se passe comme si la guerre en
Ukraine était un accélérateur de
tendance qui sont en fait à l'oeuvre
depuis des années mais aujourd'hui il
est trop tôt pour savoir en faveur de
qui le bras de fer va tourner à une
nouvelle forme de guerre froide à
redouter et à méditer en eau froide ou
chaude ou chaude en Ukraine forcément
merci merci d'Abel merci Fanny guinochet
Tibo inoc revenez quand vous voulez
merci beaucoup
refusez la cruauté du monde le temps
d'aimer est venu aux éditions du Rocher
très belle soirée documentaire à présent
avec Jean-Pierre grasseon à demain
[Musique]